c'était tellement amusant alors merci
c'est la dernière fois que nous nous verrons
chose que mon
mari m'a trompée je cherchais
quelqu'un avec qui avoir une liaison pour que je
puisse lui jeter au visage
tu as baisé ta dernière femme Stensland non
non tu as uriné dans ton short tu l'as
bien pointé dans mon visage et j'avais déjà
aller
l'infidélité de Morgan
m'enhardit prends des vacances j'emménage ici pendant un
moment ce que tu as dit que ça ressemblait à un
bateau pirate et sentait les nouilles au boeuf
et tu as dit que ça sentait l'homme et tu
étais juste ici je vis ici maintenant un  femme
nous nous sommes liés par la haine mutuelle de toi
organisé je ne te déteste pas en soi tais
toi d'accord s'il te plaît arrête de
parler maintenant d'accord arrête oh c'est tellement
tordu nous devons sortir là-bas nous devons en
avoir je dois encaisser un  bang quelques
voitures étranges non oui non boire 92% d'
alcool
tu as raison oui ça w  comme un délicieux
bain moussant Des aventures éclatent tout
autour de vous Je déteste ça Je pense qu'un gars
qui est énervé que son aventure d'un soir
ne soit pas juste une aventure d'un soir
J'ai hâte de sortir ces gens de ma
vie  Oh mariage,
il était un singe au cerveau endommagé, ils sont tous
vous
[Applaudissements]